[Music]
all right everyone i'm really excited
today to be joined by the one and only
damson idris you know him from snowfall
you also know him from black
mirror if you're watching his interview
just a heads up we are going to be
talking spoilers so come back after you
watch the film
dancing how you doing today man i'm
great man i'm incredibly excited
uh for friday we're going out to 195
million subscribers on netflix that's
insane one of the biggest openings i've
ever experienced so
yeah i can't wait yeah so this film
you're in outside the wire for netflix
you play
lieutenant harp and what i found
fascinating about your character
is the character transformation that
happens where literally in the opening
scene
you send this drone to
save to save 38 to kill two and then at
the end
you do the complete opposite from a
similar but more heightened
experience can you kind of just go into
that a little bit and explain like
what you think the transformation was
for the character of lieutenant harp
when we first meet harp he's this hot
shot drone pilot
who chooses to do what he thinks
instinctively is the right thing
rather than following orders because of
his background
and his intelligence with being a drone
pilot his brilliance of being a draw
pilot
instead of being court-martialed they
decide to teach him a left
a lesson if you will and send him on the
front lines
uh where he meets captain leo and
they're tasked with locating a deadly
doomsday device in a militarized zone
now for me with heart the biggest thing
was to not be too prepared
uh and to be the most horrible
physical marine you could possibly see
like
i didn't want him to be able to hold a
gun well uh i didn't want him to look
cool running i wanted him to have a
stitch when he was running
because this is a guy that sits on the
chair all day eating
gummy bears you know um so
to go from that guy to the end
when he's holding those incendiary
rounds above
the amazing anthony mackie looking him
dead in his eyes and saying
humans could do better that is the
greater good
it's the most epic arc ever i've ever
seen in an action movie and it was
wonderful for me to be able to
to live through that so would you say
what you just said there is what you
think though as a whole the movie is
trying to say that
humans can do better and that we're not
we can't forget about humanity with all
this tech coming out kind of thing
that is the through line and you know
2036 it was like 15 years in the future
right
if you look at the route we're going
with it technologically
it's brilliant you know people are able
to do what we're doing now you know
usually we'd be sitting in a room or
sitting somewhere and interviewing but
i'm able to be in l.a and you're where
you are
and we're talking to each other those
are things to marvel at but i think when
you talk about
some of the stuff that happens in
outside the wire the fear is that is
around the corner
and right warfare from
far far away and having no emotion to
people's lives that you're impacting in
such a horrific manner
that's something to take a pause on so i
think this movie
comments on that comments on the
casualties of war
comments on doing the right thing rather
than doing what you're told
and comments on our relationship with
technology tech
technology yeah i i totally agree and
that's what i love about the film
i don't understand why i couldn't get
ticked no no
no it happens and yeah i agree with you
man because like just the film what i
loved about it was so clear on what it
was trying to say and it had
a set top to get to at the end with your
character and it was awesome that your
character was the one we kind of
saw the lens of the whole film through
now you mentioned the other character
captain leo played by anthony mackie i
thought you guys had great chemistry
to the point where it kind of almost
felt like a buddy cop film at some
points
so did you guys click right away and was
there something you could take away from
learning from working with anthony
mackey
um mackie always says the reason why he
wanted to make this movie was because it
reminded him of training day
denzel okay okay and that's why i wanted
to do it i love playing characters that
are playing catch-up
characters who overcome adversity at the
end
and characters who of course have a arc
and have something to say
with regards to clicking straight away
hell yeah
um i met him through a friend in l.a a
private
function and he was great then but then
when we went to budapest we knew we'd be
working with each other
we had dinner and the way this guy was
teasing me in front of everyone teasing
me in front of producers teasing me in
front of
like teasing my outfit i was like ah he
reminded me of my big brothers and
sisters
so that was the rapport on chemistry
throughout the whole movie
constantly laughing constantly making
jokes
we stayed at the four seasons but
downstairs there was this
little bar called the bob and we'd go
every single night and just laugh and he
told me stories about hollywood and
and all of that experience and those
moments were translated onto the screen
see that that's really cool and it's
like gotta be surreal being like near
this superstar you're acting with and
you guys are just
killing it together don't go anywhere he
can't go
anywhere else yes i i know you i know
you
falcon i know you
like being around like an actual
superhero like for you
is there a dream superhero you wouldn't
want to play or anyone in that kind of
canon
in your future i'd love to work in that
universe
yeah as a specific person i don't know
and
i think the beauty of those roles
are when the fans choose who you should
be i love that i love
i love when people put up like little
pictures and
they put a superhero near my face and i
don't maybe i don't know who that
superhero is and i
find out what their power is and stuff
and i think that's interesting that's
more of a build up and more
exciting for a universe that's so
established
and that is so dictated by its loyal fan
base i think it's important to give them
as much power as possible
with regards to let's play the parts i
love that
yeah i totally agree and it's
interesting because i feel like this
film had
things that you'd kind of seen superhero
movies like some of these robotic
villains that are
like gumps right and i don't even know
watching because it looks so good but
were those real robots or is that all
cgi it was all cgi
um the great thing about those guns man
because
it wasn't on the page but i spoke to
mikael on special effects
cgi and i said hey i'd love to interact
with these gumps every now and then
i want to bump into one by accident
apologize
i want to say hello i wanna and and i
think that's what
brought them to life more because on the
day it's literally
a poll with a tennis ball right
so so as an actor you're having to ask
okay how wide is this thing okay
okay show me a picture alright how tall
is it right i want us to bump into it
what part of it am i bumping into is it
torso is
arm and that was what brought them to
life
for me i also admired the difference
between the american gumps
and the insurgent scumps there was a
clear difference there
um but just going forward man it's only
made me respect
that piece of art form even more is
there anything no
when you're mentioning like actually
like looking at a tennis ball on a
string is there like
anything actually easier about green
screen or like blue screen acting
yeah there's no limits right the funny
thing is i was petrified because
i'm used to playing these small
characters in these really intricate
locations small scenes
and to go to something this large scale
and to truly be my most childlike self
it was amazing i was able to tap into my
imagination and what you don't realize
is yes although there's a clear thing
that you're looking at
and what special effects hopes to put on
the screen
that thing is also reacting to you and
they have all of the power
in post to make it as tall or as short
or as wide or as movie as it is
comparing on how you reacted to it
and i think that's what they did in
outside the wire we were able to add
stuff in
adr um there's a scene after
we first are introduced to um emily
beacham's character
and we're walking into her office and
there's a gump standing guard
on the day i just walked i looked at him
walked right past but in adr i was like
hey it'll be hilarious if i was like
hello and it made it into the movie you
know
oh that's awesome there's no limitations
when you're working with these things
and that's
the beauty about it yeah and what you
just mentioned too that like child like
joy of like the green screen
speaking of that what is that sweater
you're wearing
uh it's burberry oh i love that
yeah pikachu all right well
dancing i had so much fun talking to you
is there anything else you want to plug
besides outside the wire
well i'm obviously very excited for
people to see this movie and
i can't wait for people to tap into
season four of snowfall
on fx and hulu on february 24th
yeah can't wait for that as well
everybody make sure to check out outside
the wire if you haven't watched it if
you haven't
watched it already watch it again again
thank you so much damson for joining me
and i hope to talk to you again one day
in the future
bless you thank you so much steve thank
you